that ultimately women's full and equal  participation in society at every level  including bodily autonomy is fundamental  to democracy functioning  what does that woman think democracy  means  democracy is government by the people  that's all democracy is democracy is  when people vote in the majority rules  that's democracy  in what world is abortion necessary for  democracy  what if most people  vote to Outlaw abortion she's really  saying liberalism writ large  is essential to democracy now that's not  true it's not you can have you can have  a conservative democracy you can have a  communist democracy you can have a  liberal democracy you can have a fascist  democracy you can democracy is just what  the what the majority of people want  right that's all that is